[MUSIC PLAY]
DANIEL BARRETO: Haystack TV started in 2013
as a new venture from Stanford StartX accelerator.
We were frustrated with how news is being distributed,
because every time we turn on the TV,
we had to watch the same news as everyone else.
Our angle here at Haystack TV
is that we enable people to do that
watch news they care about.
One of the decisions we had to make at the beginning
was what platform we had to start with.
As a small new business, we needed a platform
which would allow us to repeat quickly.
We got it with Android.
ISH HARSHAWAT: The team at Haystack TV
love working with Android.
The documentation is very clear and easy to use.
It can be fun to program for Android.
DANIEL BARRETO: Our users wanted the news
in their living rooms, on their TVs.
And there wasn't a platform out there for them to do it.
ISH HARSHAWAT: Many of the smart TVs to date
are quite wealthy closed systems
to which developers like us hard to get access.
With Android TV we could finally penetrate
into the living room.
Although a developer can easily take their mobile application
And sitting on Android TV, we found it to work very well
to actually design a first-for-Android TV type experience.
It was very fast to develop for Android TV.
We did it literally in two weeks.
DANIEL BARRETO: We've seen incredible results
after we integrated with Android TV and Chromecast.
Our mobile users initially
an average of 40 minutes a week
spend watching the news.
Now we've doubled it.
Our growth path is very strong at the moment.
We managed to grow more than 40% month-on-month
since we started.
And much of it is the integration with the TVs.
It's a new beta test feature that released Android.
This allowed us to reach our early beta and alpha testers.
And that also allowed us to integrate with Google+,
so that we can reach different communities of early contractors.
It was incredibly powerful for us.
A small business like ours is now making a big impact
with just six people, reaching out to millions of users.
And many of them are due to the tools and platforms
what we have with Google.